[Music]
margaret's office
it's jerry who is this
i want to stay in new york for a while
what about your semester i don't want to
analyze
other people's work anymore carl i want
to write how about a literary agency
great but do you type on a typewriter
it's very different from typing on one
of those computers did she give you her
speech about the evils of the digital
age yet
so there are no computers i've seen them
in action they just make more work for
everyone
[Music]
you published poetry yes leave that out
writers make the worst assistance get to
work
there were hundreds of us working at
literary agencies or publishing houses
we wanted to be writers ourselves you're
a novelist yourself
joanna is my assistant i don't hire
writers
i'm guessing my boss represents and rice
the pope thomas pynchon
jd salinger no way salinger
i'm sure you've heard that he's crazy
he's not the problem it's these people
who relentlessly call for his address
his phone number dear mr salinger i read
the catcher in the right three times now
i got these literally a bunch of
obsessive freaks
salinger's fan mail you need to answer
them so salary doesn't get any of his
mail
not one mr salinger does not wish to
receive mail from his readers did you
send my letter to mr salinger you send
my letter to silently you have no right
to keep my letter
jerry likes you i am reluctant to alter
his routine
i don't want to be a routine what did
you plan on doing
you keep saying you want to write but
you work long hours for other writers
well you really have to love it you have
to want it more than anything in the
entire world
don't get stuck answering the phone
joanna your
poet you've crossed the line it's a huge
rabbit hole ethically and legally all
right
you've had your fun
[Applause]
[Music]
i didn't want to be ordinary
i wanted to be extraordinary
[Music]
[Music]
you